every interview I'm sure you're asked
about Harry Potter I've never
shot away from it I'm proud to be a part
of it it was a huge part of my life I
wouldn't be here if it wasn't for that
yeah I mean still it's amazing that it's
finding new Forbes as well and people
are still really enthusiastic about it
and they want more so it's
yeah it's great yeah very proud you're a
little scary sometimes you know that
what happened you talk to everybody
um yeah that would again we do I mean
it's a reunion like oh I loved it yeah
well that was a big one it was kind of
nice to kind of get everyone in the same
place and
just yet D debrief ratings we've never
really got a chance to kind of do that
really it was also kind of fast and it
ended just it felt so suddenly but um
it's yeah it was a crazy time but um so
much fun it's a strong a strong bond
that we'll always have and
we will always be part of each other's
life
what can I say I'm full of surprises did
you watch weird the Daniel Radcliff
Weird Al movie oh no yeah no I haven't
seen it yet that's so good yeah no so I
really want to see he's he's just yeah
he's the best he's so versatile at just
he can morph into anyone it's incredible
we were called
and are united by a common vision
which has now become a command
that we cannot ignore tell me about how
you kind of came into this role yeah it
was just a fascinating concept and it
just felt very classic night and just
really fun and I love working with I
I've kind of got to know him over the
years doing server the TV series and
uh yeah it's kind of a vibrator it's
just ticks every box for me if I could
only do night movies for the rest of my
career be great
did Webster come to Sir she did she had
a birthday in the cabin at the cabin wow
yeah it wasn't a
flashbacks back a bit but um yeah
[Music]